hi i'm vishy anand
and what i'm going to do now is to
try out these new bots on chess.com
i'm probably going to try out anish i'll have
to do myself and uh maybe one more thing but
let you know let's let's just give it a twirl and
see how much fun it is uh incidentally there's a
lot of them you can do that you can do bloody so
have fun okay so um let's play against some bots
i don't know where to start but let's start with
anishikiri and i think that is now the option so
yeah no help and let's just
see how that goes okay before
okay let's do that
okay this is uh quite a sharp line um let's
okay that is kind of unusual
for me because i expect
okay he's gonna go for all the pawns is
he okay let's get the king out of the way
and then prop that up there
okay knight beat three
oh did i miss something ah clever
have i been
that is annoying
let's take that and hope for the best it should
still be good for me but you don't feel quite
the same way two pawns down against a computer
as you do with human beings but i've still got
a good lead in development so let's see where
this goes okay i think the check is gonna be
i'm gonna be quite happy to get a
check in nope he's not gonna allow me
okay let's put the rook in there
should i play bishop c7 should i go to c1 i
don't know where to go group d1 what would
he goes e6
okay let's try that
okay i think uh yes that works so
check and take these and luckily i've got
my knight f1 so i should be okay over there
in fact let me just go ahead and do that
and then i can put the bishop
there which should slow him down a bit okay
so everybody is happy i can go to case seven
and i and if i go queen c7 then
things are coming along rather nicely
so bishop c5 collect the pawn and
okay now it's winning so this is
that was fun it's funny a position i would take
very happily against any human being against
the computer you still have to see whether
you're missing a pawn here or upon there
uh but now i'm a piece up
so all good let's go hitch
you know what let's exchange the roots
i'd rather not have to calculate anything
yeah and now i'll come back the queen and bishop
cling to each other oh he's
gonna go for that so let me
swap the ships
and he's going to go h4 h3
if i go bishop c3 he goes
h4 bishop takes f6 annoying he can't
do that so let's get rid of the bishops
okay funny boy
oh this is very nice it's simplifying
to an endgame which is what i want to do
let's do a little razzle dazzle
and then do that pick up the g4 pawn
okay
it's hard to believe that i'm going to
have technical difficulties here but
i'm pretty sure i will
anyway um should i go g4 should i open tonight
let's go here just see what he wants to do
okay let me come back ah that
was incredibly sweet of him
and i think i can step around it's quite
strange that he's uh simplifying into like
okay it's a bottle so let let's not go
over the top here with a lot of analysis
okay eventually initial resign
let's get that on one step
let's get it another step
let's get it one more step and the king is
gonna run back so this should be easy peasy
okay that's fun
so you didn't want to under
promote no apparently not
i must say one of the nice
things about playing these
bots is all the witty sentences
that have been programmed in so
of course some of them get repeats fine